foreign
[Music]
yeah you read that right Kim Kardashian
is set to star in the upcoming season of
American Horror Story with Emma Roberts
I don't know how you're gonna top that
on Monday the reality star shared a
teaser for the 12th season of the FX hit
on Instagram the clip features the
message Emma Roberts and Kim Kardashian
are delicate set to a very scary version
of Rock-a-bye Baby
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I'm already scared Kim captioned the
clip with the wide eyes and blood drop
Emoji while Emma shared the same clip
writing this summer Kim and I are
delicate of course American Horror Story
is known for keeping the details of each
season under wraps so we don't know
anything about Kim's role or her
connection to Emma's character but we
are ready and waiting to hear more it's
a different experience for sure we do
know the show's co-creator Ryan Murphy
is excited Kim's joining the cast well
you know I always say in my company and
in my career that you know
success is opportunity in a statement to
The Hollywood Reporter Ryan explained
Kim is among the biggest and brightest
television stars in the world and we are
thrilled to welcome her to the AHS
family thank you according to the outlet
casting came together after Ryan was
impressed by Kim's Saturday Night Live
hosting debut Travis baby I have to do
my show I can't help it your honor the
role marks Kim's first acting part in
over a decade she had minor roles in CSI
New York detective Flack
my name is Debbie Fallon you're holding
my boyfriend Sam Baker Disaster Movie
those guys are trying to steal our blues
and Drop Dead Diva I do
I'm kind of surprised you're not being
more supportive she also played herself
in How I Met Your Mother you're here on
the set of How I Met Your Mother what
are you doing here doll I got a call to
um you know be a guest star on the show
I'm a little nervous but more really
excited 30 Rock wow 2.5 million people
just saw that uh now 14 million people
just saw it you're welcome oh and also I
broke your toilet and Two Broke Girls
and while she wasn't acting on screen
it's worth noting Kim voiced Dolores in
Paw Patrol the movie in 2021 mayor
humdinger's goons took over this place
and turned it into a jail she'll be back
for the sequel alongside her daughter
Northwest which I'm really excited about
as for Emma the role is huge for fans of
the series I would give everything I
have or will ever have just to feel pain
again
to hurt she first appeared in Coven back
in season three but hasn't been on the
show since 2019. that was season nine
the camp themed 1984. and while we wait
to learn more about Emma and Kim's roles
in the upcoming season we know Kim's got
that scream and cry down hey there's a
spider on you no there's not much
Kim the little drama queen
[Music]
foreign